and then I was looking at obviously the
resume there's great moments that you've
called you've witnessed Koufax
no-hitters Koufax perfect game Hank
Aaron's 715 homerun
Gibby's home run off Eckersley in the
World Series is there one that you think
you got it right with your standards
well I'll put it this way it's been
referred to the perfect game and they
celebrated it at the New York Writers
dinner last winter I didn't go back but
Tom Verducci was the emcee and he
saluted Bob Henley to pitcher and he
saluted Sandy Koufax the pitcher and
then much to my surprise he saluted me
saying it was the perfect broadcast for
the perfect game I've never listened to
it again or anything like that but it
was on radio and that's a huge
difference in fact I thought about that
two years ago when Clayton Kershaw
pitched a no-hitter and I was doing it
on television
and it removed the announcer completely
I thought because there he was doing
what he does and when he finally got the
last out I said he's done it but the
Koufax perfect game was on radio and now
I'm describing him running his hands
through his hair drying the hand off on
his pants leg whatever and it was a
totally different broadcast and I
realized when you're doing a perfect
game on television you're just saying
there it is or whatever something simple
because the viewer is looking at the
whole thing radio it's up to you to
describe the whole thing so maybe that
was that was perhaps if you don't mind
me saying it in lower-case my finest
hour but also it takes you back to when
you're eight years of age and the sound
you're you've got to capture everything
you're listening on the radio so it it
it brings you back to that what
resonated with you when you do something
on the radio
that's what I fell in love with Al
Michaels and Marty Brennaman Joe Nuxhall
calling Reds games on the radio and then
you watch TV and you went no I'd rather
listen to the radio if I'm gonna watch
TV yeah I agree there's not very much
you can do on television I've often
explained it as best I could you walk
into the into the booth the broadcasting
booth and there is a blank canvas and if
it's radio you then spend three hours
with the big brushes the fine brushes
your shading you're making impacts and
after three hours you stand up and you
look at the canvas and you say well
that's the best I could do today in
television you walk in and the canvas is
already covered so then all you do is do
a little Asterix footnote kind of a
description of the game so it's totally
different and I think if you tried to do
radio on a television broadcast you
would butcher it
you knew Jackie Robinson obviously there
when he broke in and I'm curious and
maybe it's not fair to have you speak
for him but how do you think Jackie
would react to what we're seeing now
with the demonstrations prior to the
start of the star-spangled banner'
Dan I'm not dodging the question
I just don't know I think you said it in
leading up to that I really don't know I
know Jackie would be very sensitive to
the issue but whether he would publicly
say I agree or whether he would think
something else like I wish he had done
something more important than that I
really honest to god don't know what
Jackie would have said or done but I do
know he would have been sensitive to the
issue of course yeah I still amazed that
he what he didn't do like he he he kept
everything inside so his his
demonstration was watch me as a
ballplayer I still marvel at that and I
don't know I mean when you watched it
realizing what is going on with him and
still able to go out and play at
Hall of Fame level it's still amazing
yes and who was a tremendous competitor
I mean really I can tell you one brief
story I guess it was my second or third
year with the team and the Dodgers asked
me the Brooklyn Dodgers asked me to go
up to the Catskill Mountains to a resort
called Grossinger's they were going to
have kind of a Q&A with the people who
were up there and so I said sure fine
and it was dead of winter and it just
happened that I arrived at the same time
as Jackie and Rachel and Rachel was
probably I don't know six seven months
pregnant and I had my ice skates and
Jackie said wow you're going to skate
and I said well yeah I being an
Easterner I've been on skates since I
was a little kid he said oh great I'll
skate with you and I said oh that's
terrific
so he came and we went into the locker
room and they got a pair of skates for
him and we were putting our skates on
and I had those long razor blades and
Jackie said when we get out there I'll
race you I looked at him and I said Jack
I said I know you a football player and
a baseball player and a great athlete I
didn't know he skated you're in Southern
California and Jackie looked at me very
seriously and he said well I've never
been on skates in my life oh I was kind
of shocked and I said Jack look I'm not
a great skater nothing but I can skate
I've been skating forever since I was a
little kid so I said there's really no
way you're gonna beat me and Jack again
very serious he said no but that's how I
learned
that's how dedicated he was of course
when we got up he walked on his ankles
he have and somewhere in the house and a
book somewhere I guess there's a picture
of Jackie and me lining up as if we're
at the starting line ready to race
against each other and I know Jackie's
daughter when she wrote a book about her
father of all the millions of pictures
she could have put in that book she put
the one of Jackie and me ready to escape
but they think really she was making the
same point that impressed me he was that
much of a competitor that he would learn
under the pressure of competition how to
skate
you've got jackets and gloves on VIN I'm
looking at the picture and your hair
looks grow you got it yeah yeah I think
it was you know December January
somewhere where you went up and you
talked to all the people and they ask
questions about baseball and the game
and those who played it and yeah that
was that was all part of the deal on
behalf of America enjoy retirement thank
you for everything
Dan thank you for allowing me to speak
to you and your listeners it's been a
great ride God has been extremely
generous to me and for that my last day
will not be a sad day at all it will be
a Thanksgiving Day Thank You Ven
alright Dan good work yes you were great
thank you I hope it worked
doesn't matter the topic you just listen
to his voice and the humility there but
that's great it's good stuff he has so
many stories that that's what I love
about listening to him broadcast a game
that something will trigger something
that then he starts talking about the
Beatles playing at Dodger Stadium and
the Hells Angels got them out of Dodger
Stadium or he'll talk about beards it's
just to have that ability and I don't
you can't teach that you can't teach
that style
unless you're teaching people to listen
be a good listener and I think that's
what VIN has done for his entire career
he's listening the fact you'll take your
headset at Augusta and he took the
microphone and put it behind him so he
wouldn't have the temptation to say
anything and if you listen to
broadcasters now there is
the propensity to want to say something
to say too much and that's that's the
brilliance event being a great listener
and giving you the feel of again not
telling you but letting you almost feel
that game through the radio the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience